jim carrey played the evil dr robotnik
in this year's sonic the hedgehog which
went on to gross over 300 million
dollars worldwide
so what's jim's next chapter well it's
unlike
anything he's ever done you say about
this book
none of it is real and all of it is true
it's
basically using fiction to tell a deeper
truth
this book is about the fear of erasure
and the ego and its
addiction to relevance yeah
this gym is very different from the guy
we're used to seeing
somebody stop me
[Music]
alrighty then his new
semi-autobiographical novel
memoirs and misinformation is a look
inside the 58 year old's mind
passages include his character's breakup
with a fictional renee zellweger
a wound i feared would never heal he
writes carrie and the real rene dated
for a short time in 2000
there were even engagement rumors i'm
just proud
i'm proud of them we came together
around the excitement of
doing something that nobody had ever
done jim enlisted novelist dana vashawn
to co-author and help sort through his
thoughts
a task that took eight years they're
gonna say
this is jim carrey hiding behind a
character
i mean you couldn't find another person
who's been this scathing and
disintrospective and this
is courageous i delay myself
i pull my entrails out and let the gulls
have a meal
you know what i mean does the jim carrey
in the book
feel trapped and and lonely
by his fame i think everybody who's
saying this feels lonely
i walked through the door the truman
show door
and uh was thinking i would leave it all
behind and
just recreate myself but all this
doesn't mean he doesn't like putting on
a character
i know that sonic 2 may be happening at
some point
you know which i'm really gratified by i
get to go back and
do that really off the wall silly stuff
jim was definitely off the wall 30 years
ago behind the scenes of in living color
he got emotional talking about the
groundbreaking sketch comedy show
that featured mostly black comedians and
the impact
it had on his life i wouldn't be writing
this book i wouldn't be in the place
that i
am without keenan and damon wayans
honestly i i am so grateful
and that's what it's about that
everybody unloving color was
was so great that i had to be great i
can't talk about it
very lucky